en plein coeur de washington cette
pharmacie dans ce supermarché fait
partie des quarante mille à travers le
pays qui vont offrir le vaccin
ici la vaccination a déjà commencé à 85
ans petro soit des girls guise vient de
recevoir sa deuxième dose du vaccin
contre la corruption
simple et facile dit-il le rendez-vous
ses prix en ligne rapidement car c'est
ma deuxième visite dit il je suis venu
la semaine car les fans semaine c'est
bondé les pharmacies recevront 2
millions de doses car elles sont plus
faciles d'accès que les hôpitaux dit la
maison blanche
plus de 50 millions d'américains ont été
vaccinées 15 millions déjà reçu leur
deuxième dose
la californie est l'état on vaccine le
plus ici à carson le stade est
transformée en gigantesque site de
vaccination on veut administrer six
mille doses par jour
car en 2000 par semaine on vise d'abord
les 65 ans et plus et le personnel de la
santé puis ce sera la population
générale
des militaires sont venus en renfort au
total 1100 étaient mobilisés à travers
le pays d'ici la fin juillet dit joe
byden nous aurons 600 millions de doses
assez pour vacciner chaque américain
mais la vague de froid a freiné la
distribution de vaccins dans plusieurs
états ici à houston au texas on vaccine
les jeunes étudiants pour ne pas
gaspiller les vaccins qui ont failli
être perdu à cause des coupures de
courant
j'ai 21 ans dit elle je ne fais pas
partie des personnes à risque je suis
très chanceuse que l'université a
organisé tout ça les gens autour de moi
seront mieux protégés la campagne de
vaccination va donc bon train mais il
faut rester vigilant rappellent les
autorités médicales
on s'aperçoit que les forte
contamination du virus sont reliés aux
périodes de fête ou voyage dit elle donc
il ne faut pas uniquement compter sur la
vaccination vont continuer à prendre des
précautions sanitaires
plus de 1200 cas du variant britanniques
ont déjà été détectés dans 42 états est
la grande inconnue c'est l'efficacité du
vaccin
face aux différents variant ici au dépôt
de l'igr guise radio-canada washing